this is the sound of the biggest toothed
predator on the planet
a song being broadcast from the deepest
reaches of the sea a call that sounds
less like a harmonious Melody like we
hear from other whales but more like a
digital data transfer
it's the sound that haunted Sailors for
centuries a sound which they thought to
be the cries of the ghosts of drowned
Sailors calling out to them amazingly it
wasn't until 1957 that scientists even
realized that these sounds were in fact
coming from whales and it wasn't until
the 1970s that they realized that these
undulating clicking bellowing noises
were a form of communication and now
researchers think sperm whales could be
our best chance at breaking a barrier
we've never broken that they might hold
the key to unlocking the first ever case
of inter-species communication because
if you were to bet on one animal that
had something that was even close to
human language it would be the sperm
whale over the years scientists have
learned that their brains are extremely
developed that they have Rich social and
family lives culture and an intricate
communication system to support it all
their lives in many ways are similar to
ours and their language could have
developed for similar reasons plus
they've had their massive brains for
tens of millions of years longer than
we've had our current sized brains and
with a vast repertoire of different
sounds with intricate patterns it seems
as though sperm whale language could be
as complex as our own
speaking with other animals has long
been a part of the collective human
imagination part of folklore fables and
fantasy and many different cultures but
now for the first time we have
technology that might be able to
actually break the code
recently we've all seen the huge strides
in the field of natural language
processing with chat gpt3 giving a clear
idea of what is possible when it comes
to computers in human language as
technology like this has advanced
dramatically over the last 10 years
scientists now think they can apply
these techniques to the field of
inter-species communication specifically
to sperm whales because sperm whales and
other species aren't just singing to one
another they seem to be communicating
specific messages maybe even using
language in a way that we could
understand
for thousands of years humans have
considered language to be one of the
defining characteristics of our species
and something that other animals
couldn't possibly approximate so we
hardly bothered to investigate all the
ways that animals actually are
communicating
today with better technology we're
starting to realize that many species
have complex forms of conveying
information
prairie dogs have distinctive alarm
calls for different predators and have
even used different calls to distinguish
the size shape color and speed of those
Predators male and female putty-nosed
monkeys each produce their own alarm
calls when leopards approach the female
is calling to get males to go on the
defense and the males calling to Signal
they're ready for a fight
bat squeaks aren't just echolocation to
help them hunt they sometimes contain
information about the speaker and which
other bat is being addressed even tiny
jumping spiders have a form of
communication through vibrations
the animal kingdom is clearly full of
species communicating to one another but
whether or not they're using language is
much harder to recognize
when Linguistics developed as an area of
studies specifically interested in
analyzing the differences between human
language and the mechanics of how
language works and is acquired it seemed
clear that nothing else on Earth was
communicating the way we are
human language has grammar the
overarching structure of each language
and syntax which is the order in which
words are spoken in order to convey
meaning we have the ability to create
new words and use them to communicate
information about things that happened
elsewhere or in the past or future human
languages are complex and nuanced what
we don't know is if the same is true of
any other animal but there's one species
that might be able to help us solve that
problem as we've learned more and more
about sperm whales they seem to be the
perfect candidate to put our non-human
translation abilities to the test sperm
whales make the loudest noises of any
living creature up to 230 decibels for
reference when sounds are made above the
water human eardrums rupture when noises
are louder than 150 decibels
sperm whale communities also use
discrete sequences of clicks that get
repeated in specific patterns called
codas researchers believe this is the
basic communication unit for their
language and codas differ between whales
in different regions for the whales off
the coast of Dominica a typical Coda has
five clicks and lasts for around 4
seconds they have recognizable patterns
measured by inter-click intervals codas
are mostly produced during periods of
socialization not when the whales are
hunting or engaged in other activities
and calves can take up to two years to
produce recognizable codas and before
that they Babble just like human babies
all of these elements seem like the
ingredients to a language that we might
be able to make sense of thanks to
machine learning and artificial
intelligence but how exactly can
computers help us with this never before
solved puzzle thanks to seti we may be
about to find out
the world's largest ever interspecies
communication effort was launched in
March 2020 with a project known as the
citation translation initiative or seti
if that sounds familiar it might be
because there's another moonshot project
known as seti the search for
extraterrestrial intelligence in the
case of this new citation project
scientists will be collecting data from
a group of sperm whales around the
Caribbean island of Dominica the whales
of that area have already been studied
for more than 15 years thanks to the
Dominica sperm whale project but before
we can understand how computers might
translate whale language let's first
dive into how they've done so for human
languages
since 2014 Machine translation has
largely relied on something called an
encoder decoder deep learning model
which is a system that uses two separate
neural networks the encoder is the first
neural network and is where you input a
sentence in say English the encoder
takes each word in the sentence and
turns these into a sequence of numbers
which are multi-dimensional vector
representations for each word which are
called word embeddings the second neural
network decoder will take this sequence
of numbers and output a sentence in a
different language but for this to work
it needs human supervision it relies on
known pairs of inputs and outputs a
system like this wouldn't work to
translate any language that's new or
unknown and for several years this was
the best machine learning could do that
is until 2018 a group at Facebook
research found it's possible to do
completely unsupervised translation
you do this by taking all the words from
one language and calculating their
statistical properties more or less how
often that word is used and with what
other words it's often correlated you
can then assign all the words to a point
Cloud kind of like a 3D Galaxy based on
these statistical properties then if you
do the same for a totally different
language and compare the point clouds
they have nearly identical structures a
word located in a particular position in
the galaxy in one language would be in
the same location in any other language
you can take languages as dissimilar as
English and Chinese and the structure in
the point clouds will still line up and
this means you can translate languages
without needing a Rosetta Stone
Tom muscle a documentary filmmaker and
the author of how to speak whale has
followed the work of researchers at seti
for years he is particularly thrilled
about how this development could apply
to sperm whales that's what all the
scientists excited because they thought
if we can then get a big enough core
person a big enough amount of uh
recordings and that gives you a weigh-in
with no bilingual dictionaries which is
what the situation we have with other
species and it doesn't mean that we're
going to make a cloud in sperm whale and
that it's going to match the human one
but maybe there'll be some shapes that
do maybe some parts of the universe that
they represent in their communication
does match ours but those differences
and similarities are going to give us an
idea of what the different language
galaxies that exist in in life are the
AI will be trained not just to predict
what a single whale might say next but
we'll also learn to predict what a
second whale might say like in a
conversation the result will be like a
whale chat bot but there's one caveat to
all of this for it to work you need a
ton of data like so much data for
reference chat gpt3 needed to be trained
with over 500 billion words to be able
to do what it does this is the largest
neural network that's ever been trained
maybe we don't need chat GPT 3 levels of
data but can we even get close to enough
data from sperm whales for translation
to be possible
in order to estimate how much data sperm
whale communication the seti project
might be able to gather we can do a
simple back of the envelope calculation
scientists are studying a 20 square
kilometer area off the coast of Dominica
where 50 to 400 whales are observed
depending on the season
sperm whales vocalize almost constantly
however 75 of the clicks are used for
echolocation the remaining 25 percent of
the clicks are used for communication
the coda clicks
a typical Coda from the whales in this
region is about one click per second so
dividing the number of seconds in a year
by four times the number of whales gives
us 400 million to 4 billion clicks a
year approximately so not nearly close
to chat gpt3 levels but still enough to
work with at the high end it's between
Google's Birch algorithm and chat gbt2
levels but how exactly will researchers
collect this data it's a task that will
require a host of autonomous and
semi-autonomous devices that
continuously record the whales from
above below and all around them
one source of data will be from tethered
buoy arrays these devices will collect
massive amounts of background whale
bioacoustic data these are Big devices
and work in a similar way to military
equipment that detects submarines over
large areas and distances each array
will consist of audio recording devices
that will be positioned at different
depths in 200 to 300 meter increments up
to 1200 meters which is the depth that
sperm whales are known to hunt and
attaching certain codas to certain
depths could be a particularly good
place to start looking for patterns in
their language a study done in 2016
reported that sperm whales seem to use
certain codas at certain depths some
were used on the ascent from a dive some
on The Descent and some at the surface
immediately after returning with many
hydrophone arrays in the water
scientists will also be able to track
the movements of specific whales over
space and time in addition to the static
hydrophones scientists are attaching
recording devices to the whales
themselves using suction cups these tags
provide the most detailed recordings of
the sounds that they make and also
record signals from inertial and
pressure sensors which will allow
scientists to reconstruct the whale's
motion into diving patterns
the tags are especially critical and
uniquely identifying whales and
conversations and associating the
behavioral patterns with the recordings
and at last are the autonomous sound
recording Robots free swimming and
passively floating aquatic drones will
record audio and video from multiple
animals simultaneously to observe
behaviors and conversations within a
group of whales this will hopefully
cover any blind spots from the first two
methods all of this data will be
combined into a complex array of data
which can then be parsed out by
different algorithms so what they're
really doing is they're working with a
whole different Suite of machine
learning tools some of them will be
looking through all the audio and their
job will be to figure out when a sperm
whale is making a sound or not is that
the sound of a landslide is that the
sound of a sperm whale then they'll have
to filter out is the sperm whale
echolocating or is it a sperm while
making a communication vocalization like
a coder and then they'll have to
separate them out then they'll have to
figure out who's talking and where were
they talking and what else was going on
because that sort of metadata you know
was it the one that then fought with the
other one was it the one that was
hunting was it the one that was nursing
it's young and what relationship does it
have to the other sperm whales who were
involved in that vocalization exchange
who could have heard it what was the sea
doing then they'll try and figure out
okay well how different it is to the
kind of things that have been said
before and how many different kinds of
sounds do they make and that's when you
start to sort of have hypotheses about
meaning what do you think they might be
communicating about
researchers have already collected
around a hundred thousand sperm whale
codas and tied each call to specific
whales an algorithm was created to
analyze these codas and categorize them
by which whale made which call and it
was accurate more than 94 of the time
but this experiment will not be without
its challenges there are so many
variables in any given Coda that it will
be extremely difficult to parse what is
Meaningful and what is not for example
many of the clicks have almost the same
structure but with slight variations
like codas with a different amplitude or
a different frequency are these
variations akin to differences in
pronunciation or are these fundamental
variations that have different meanings
and does the unsupervised machine
learning translation model rely on
something innately human for it to work
we might use the words in a sentence to
describe how we're feeling for example I
feel happy today but to translate this
into whale assumes they have the same
sense of self that we do that they have
similar emotions as we do that they
perceive time in the same way we do
there are some words that are more
likely to be common between us words
like mother baby Friend or Foe but just
as a whale might not understand the
concept behind a word like today what
might a whale have a word for that we
can't even conceptualize
so even if the seti researchers are able
to collect all of this information about
sperm whales it's impossible to say
whether they'll be able to translate the
codas in a way that would make sense to
us as language but even if we can't
directly translate everything that
they're saying researchers hope that
there will still be some patterns we can
recognize some fragments of language
that can tell us more about their lives
their families or even their intentions
or problems because the attempt to
understand whales whether successful or
not might also be a way for us to care
for and help them
a thing that's really struck me through
my whole career was the more that you
can relate to other species the more you
care about them all ocean ecosystems are
under threat from climate change and
cetaceans are among those groups the
Marine Heat Wave known as The Blob that
formed over the Pacific Ocean from 2014
to 2016 resulted in crashing fish and
whale populations even without extreme
heat waves the oceans are still getting
warmer which means cold water species
like the white beaked dolphin are having
to find new habitats the availability of
food is changing and runoff from the
shoreline could eventually lead to
cetaceans being poisoned by different
chemicals and on top of this the
shipping industry has regular impacts on
cetacean populations shipping lanes that
overlap with important whale habitats
can lead to whales being struck and the
noise of vessels can disrupt hunting and
vocalizations whales and dolphins are
facing a difficult future in large part
due to human activity language is after
all the tool that propelled humans to
innovate and solve so many of the
problems that once Afflicted us it's an
evolutionary advantage that likely
allowed us to dominate The Globe and its
origins in our species is one of the
greatest mysteries of modern science
did language suddenly develop in humans
or did we earn our voices through the
slow incremental process of natural
selection that marks all other aspects
of evolution did language only ever
develop in our species Homo Sapien or
did the other early humans use language
too this is a hotly debated extremely
exciting corner of science Linguistics
and Archeology and to understand the
great debate and hear the most
compelling theories you should watch our
brand new episode of becoming human on
nebula how humans started speaking this
is the fourth episode in our Flagship
series about human evolution which takes
you through the most important steps in
our Evolution that made us the
incredible strange Apes that we are
today for this series we've created our
own world in 3D to show you the
artifacts fossils and archaeological
digs all in one place like a magical
Museum of all of the most incredible
aspects of early human in archeology
this is a series that wouldn't have
really made sense to put here on YouTube
it's a series we wanted to take our time
with and a series that's more
archaeological and more philosophical
than what we normally do here but it's a
subject so important to the innate
desire we all have of trying to
understand our own humanity and that's
why we created this series for nebula
nebula is a streaming platform that was
created by us by the educational YouTube
content creators who wanted to
experiment play and just create more
sometimes the content we want to make is
experimental too long too short or
contains themes that would get it
demonetized instantly on YouTube
sometimes we want to make content that
doesn't exactly fit on our regular
YouTube channels or sometimes like in
the case of becoming human we wanted to
make a beautiful Standalone piece
signing up to nebula is also the single
best thing you can do to support this
channel by signing up you're directly
supporting us getting to watch all of
your favorite content ad free and also
getting access to tons of exclusive
content nebula is now also offering a
nebula first content where you can get
some of your favorite creators shows
weeks or months before they're on
YouTube like jet lag the game or
episodes from Johnny Harris legal eagle
and many more and on top of the original
content and nebula First videos if you
sign up with my link you get free access
to nebula classes where creators host
classes on how to make the content you
know and love all of the classes are
taught by the creators on nebula so you
can learn how Alex the low spec gamer
makes videos on a budget or how foreign
tells stories or how Patrick Willems
makes movies your favorite creators
teaching you how they create if you've
ever wanted to become a content creator
video maker or are just curious how it
all gets done this is a great place to
start
so if you sign up for nebula using the
link below you can get nebula for a
little over two dollars and fifty cents
a month or 30 dollars for the entire
year a portion of the subscription fee
goes directly to us and the rest goes
towards building this platform to become
the best streaming platform out there
for viewers and creators It's Quickly
becoming the hub for online creators and
now is the best time to join